time now for our Bloomberg click take
where we provide context and background
on issues of interest tax inversions
took center stage this month when
Treasury secretary Jack Lew rolled out
new rules against them inversion is a
financial exercise that allows companies
to lower their tax bills by buying a
legal address abroad through M&A so
here's the situation more than 50 US
companies have reincorporated in low-tax
countries since 1982 including more than
20 since 2012 a lot of drug companies
are doing it and low tax ireland is a
popular corporate home it's how metronic
the medical device giant that began in
minneapolis in 1949 turned Irish Pfizer
also wanted to become Irish by buying
allergen a u.s. run drug maker with an
Irish tax domicile but it was stopped by
the Treasury rules here's the background
the US corporate income tax rate of
thirty five percent is the highest in
the developed world the u.s. is also one
of the few countries that makes its
companies pay that rate on all their
worldwide income many countries
including the UK and Canada tax only
domestic profits one perverse result is
that an independent US company can end
up paying more taxes than an identical
US company owned by a foreign parent the
change in address actually doesn't even
mean a real move because companies are
free to keep their top executives in the
US and most of them do so here's the
argument Treasury's new tightened rules
have made inversion deals less
attractive but the White House has
warned that only legislation can stop
them completely neither Democrats and
Republicans like inversions but they
disagree on what to do about them
Republicans call them the inevitable
consequence of a flaw tax system
although some Democrats agree on the
broad outlines of a corporate tax
revision the parties to disagree on so
many other things there's little chance
a big tax bill will actually pass
Congress anytime soon